and he's got electric stuff
upper 90s on the fastball
he's got that knuckle change
occasionally
makes in a two seamer and a curveball no
score in the top of the first with one
out and a runner in scoring position for
the astro
correa hits a line drive base hit to
left field springer is going to take the
turn and be waved home and the astros on
the board
on a carlos correa rbi single it's one
nothing
kyle tucker will take his turn sends
that ball high in the air to center
field
pretty well hit all the way back towards
the wall that ball's gone
kyle tucker goes opposite field for a
two run
shot his fourth home run of the year and
the astros out to a quick three-nothing
lead
swing and a miss gets them runner takes
off at first and machado throw down to
second base and it'll hit manny
and kick into center field so he keeps
on going it's all the way out to
springer and machado rounds third
[Applause]
on the ground right side altuve is going
to need zach covering
to make the play for the final out zach
had one strikeout in the first
inning
and he picks up a strikeout of myers
there gets him on the inside edge with a
fastball
there's a ball flared to left field kyle
tucker on the move and he makes a diving
tumbling catch
for the final out of the inning he's
doing it all
zach greinke a one two three inning
three and two
[Applause]
what does he go with the change up
confidence in the change up here it
comes
that a boy struck him out struck out
grisham
in the first inning deals with him here
in the third with two outs
and the base is empty here we go he's
doing his own signs
yep
oh there it is unknown pitch
at 54 miles an hour the unknown
what is that i think that's just a good
old-fashioned ethics
flip it up there yeah christian just has
to smile
i have to use baggy's word he is special
brother
oh yeah dots them up 54
lob ball followed by a fastball on the
outside edge at the knees are you
kidding me he's that cricket
first pace one out padres down three
nothing here in the fourth inning
osmore to right field that's a fair ball
headed towards the corner as tatis
racing around the base is going to be
waved around as reddick fires it back in
but the padres are on the board it's an
rbi double for eric hosmer
three to one now the astros are on top
but here come the padres
first and second with one down
cronenworth to right field struck well
back by the wall and off the wall
coming from second is hosmer he will
score throw goes to second
and the padres are back within a run boy
this
kid is swinging a hot chileli astros are
walking off the field here
grenkey is walking off the field with
maldonado
and the umpires have gotten together i
have no idea what they're doing here
right now
called out the padres grounds crew to
kind of clean up that landing spot
stay at the beach for zach yeah he's
just hey what you guys working
i'll just be here you guys let me know
when you're done thumbs up
ready to go bring it so the situation is
this
first and third one out runner goes at
first and a ground ball right side
altuve will go to first runway score in
this game is tied in the back door
is will myers and it is three to three
jltuve zo for two
fish's pitch ground ball backhand to t
up goes to second
back to first oh goodness you can't turn
a better play than that you can't start
a better double play
than that with fernando tatties
bloop to short left and out goes tatis
to make the catch up into the air like
superman it's fernando tati's junior
how about going and getting it in short
left field for tatis
but springer's like really dude i
thought he had no
chance at this come on nobody does that
here tatis runner goes machado swing
sends one out to right field
reddick going back at the whoa that is
gone
a two-run home run for maddie machado
padres break the tie and take a 5-3 lead
manny machado with his eighth of the
year and it's 5-3
san diego
correa flares one to center out goes
cronerworth to make the catch in shallow
center for out number one
[Music]
[Applause]
pops it up
[Applause]
machado in the shift two down in the
ninth inning
in the air to left center field grisham
the centerfielder
makes the catch of the padres win they
sweep the texas teams and win
seven straight